on va les retrouver maintenant tout près
de kiev une mère de famille qui est en
train de vivre en direct tout et ces
événements ongaro gaza bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes enseignante de français vous
avez deux enfants vous vivez à kiev mais
vous avez décidé de vous éloigner de la
ville où êtes vous actuellement
je suis à la campagne elles sont
kilomètres de kiev
la région de kiev votre mari n'est pas
avec vous et il est que fait-il il est
resté à kiev il a décidé de résister il
est allé rejoindre la défense
territoriale
et voilà donc en ce moment ils seraient
les rues de kiev est-ce qu'il a une
compétence comme militaire est ce qu'il
ce qu'il connaît le maniement des armes
non il est informaticien de métier
mais il a reçu kalachnikov et voilà donc
je pense qu'il a appris le manipuler
et puis voilà qu'est ce qui l'a motivé à
faire ça madame rosa
c'est le sentiment de ses pas
c'est quelque chose qu'on sait notre
terre c'est notre ville c'est notre vie
on doit défendre tout simplement parce
que au mail à la famille ici
vous savez aujourd'hui
la le sentiment qu'on éprouve
contre les russes et la haine donc
tout ce qui se passe on pouvait même pas
imaginer il ya deux jours de deuil à
deux jours c'était une autre vie pour
nous il ya deux jours on avait la vie
comme partout dans l'île dans les
grandes villes moi j'ai enseigné à
l'université il allait au travail mes
enfants allaient à l'école mais là tout
c'est vous le verset tout simplement ses
eaux comme je parle avec mes amis on se
dit ben c'était dans une autre vie on a
l'impression qu'on a vécu déjà au mois
deux mois depuis le commencement de la
guerre donc voila voila le sentiment
c'est parce que c'est
on ne peut pas faire autrement mais il
va affronter votre mari des soldats
professionnels des soldats russes dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes est ce que
vous êtes très inquiète pour lui je suis
affolé bien sûr on le comprend très bien
que ces sondes et des soldats russes
professionnelle mais au moins les
événements d
aujourd'hui de cette journée la deuxième
journée de la guerre montrent que
finalement on arrive à les arrêter parce
que de crise matin il ya eu déjà des
russes qui ont pénétré dans la ville les
soldats russes des diversions ministre
russe mais
c'est ils étaient arrêtés ils étaient
tués comme ça sur place et bombe à notre
maire de kiev et l'annoncé j'ai regardé
à la télé son discours il ya quelques
minutes et l'annoncé que la nuit va être
très difficile surtout le matin et déjà
tout de suite à 21h ils ont 21 heures
chez nous ils ont annoncé que en attend
une attaque aérienne
et alors je suis avec mes copines mes
collègues en misant gère tout le monde
ils sont tous partis
se cacher dans l'est dans les abris
métro les stations de métro
alors c'est je suis affolé la six mois à
la campagne c'est calme
j'entends rien on est étonné éloignés
mais à kiev je suis tout le temps avec
eux je fermais sanger ou par téléphone
mais c'est cet affreux tout ce qui se
passe comment vos enfants vivent ça
madame rosa de savoir que leur père est
allé affronter les soldats ressac hier
je leur ai je leur expliquais
des essais de ce cépage il le montre
peut-être parmi le grand il est déjà
hélas 15 ans donc il comprend pas mal de
choses la petite et les inquiètent bien
sûr mais bon j'essaie de rester calme
avec eux parce que et les enfants
ressentent l'état d'esprit le tas de
deux des adultes donc je sais me tenir
en main mais c'est vrai c'est difficile
est ce que vous vous serez abandonné est
ce que vous sentez abandonné par la
communauté internationale comment vous
le ressentez comment comment vous voyez
ça parce qu'on voit votre président qui
crient à l'aide carrément qu'ils
venaient à mener des troupes venez nous
supporter et comment vous comme
citoyenne v saint
lô et vous savez je n'avais pas beaucoup
d'espoir d'avoir
de l'aide européenne ou de l'occident
ona on re cela pas mal de d'armes en
suisse a aussi dans les actualités on
parle beaucoup que l'europe nous envoie
des armes et l'europe nous donne de
l'aide financière mais c'est c'est peu
finalement on est comme ça on est resté
tout seul tête à tête avec avec le russe
c'est le russe qui sont la russie qui
était un pays énorme deuxième armée du
monde et nous tous petits qui sont
restés comme ça ben on demande on
comprend que vous que les occidentales
pas
commencé
à intervenir dix ans parce que ça va ça
va signifier que c'est la troisième
guerre mondiale carrément mais au moins
nous aider
avec les armes
nous unissent vous savez dans les
réseaux sociaux ce moment on demande de
tous les ukrainiens envoie les messages
par prouve avec la demande de boucliers
à rien donc pour protéger le ciel au
moins au mois comme ça parce que avec
une attaque aérienne qu'on a annoncé par
exemple tout à l'heure ça fait peur
vraiment inquiet va kiev qui est
certain c'est très grande ville et pris
recevoir des missiles c'est l'enfer
donc est ce aussi leur l'occident
pourrait faire quelque chose moi tu avec
le ciel là on serait déjà reconnaissant
madame heureux hasard la nuit va être
longue
on est de tout coeur avec vous ce que
vous vivez et épouvantable alors mère de
famille deux enfants le mari qui est
parti sans formation militaire essayer
de défendre son pays et sa ville merci
infiniment pour ce témoignage qui est
très précieuse
oeuvre